I'm eight and a half months pregnant with a daughter,...
…and never in a million years did I think that I would have to fight for,...
…a basic, fundamental right for myself and for her.
Right now, you can't force a corpse to give up its organs without paperwork,...
…but, you can force me to have a baby I don't want.
I think that, you know, taking this step backwards, we now need my generation,...
…people my age,...
...to step up and fight so that we're not going back in time because it's 2022.
We don't need to go back to the 70s, to the 60s.
We can't go back.
It's time to move forward.
Steely determination.
It's what we're going to need to keep fighting this...
...by supporters of abortion rights at protests all across the country,...
…starting Friday night, over the weekend,...
...as we witness and live in the first few days of a post-Roe America.
From the New York Times, quote, "The expanding battle over abortion set off...
...by the Supreme Court's decision to overturn Roe vs. Wade,...
...is moving to state courts and legislatures,...
…with a Florida judge scheduled today...
...to hear a challenge under state law to a ban taking effect this week.
California lawmakers are preparing to put a constitutional amendment on the ballot...
...to protect reproductive rights.